this is the problem with New York if you
can't walk to it you can't get to it a
lot of the time like like everybody goes
all the subway to Subway it's like bro
I'm not taking the subway to the Best
Buy to buy a flat screen the Subway's
great if you're hopping your nine to
five like that state yeah or you're a
[__] kid backpacking around the city
like I'm like if you got [__] you got to
do like real errands to run like the
subway is not always great dude I used
to have a joke when I lived in
Williamsburg the first time because it
was great so you need a pair of socks
you know like you're like you just want
to go to a [__] Target and get a pair
of socks like I don't need Artisan right
hand knitted [__] socks from some
Bolivian kid you know what I mean
who opened this dream store on Bedford
Avenue like Jesus Christ man I need a
pair of [__] socks you need a pair of
generic Sweatshop socks that are 2.99
for three yeah